my recording software on here so we'll
start in English yeah that's fine
okay but if you want I have I have a
camera and just so we have like I mean
better quality I could set it up real
quick it's up to you I mean the quality
looks pretty good but go ahead and I
also have blue snowball yeah well we're
going to I don't know what we will talk
about we might want to talk about
learning Japanese because sometimes
people ask me about learning Japanese
and of course you're learning Japanese
and that's something yeah we can talk
about that in English and in Russian and
then we'll finish off for speaking in
Japanese and that might be of interest
to two people both English speakers and
Russian speakers who follow my youtube
channel all right that sound good to me
all right so new camera the other kappa
is this the new camera no i-i'll have it
separately and then I'll send you okay
but you know what that may not really
work because I my software
it's called recorder it's set up to film
both of us in a split screen so I think
that'll be good enough so probably your
other camera won't come into use
I think well we could still edit the
video and okay have the two the two Homs
nearby next by if I'm technically
capable of doing that I might get some
help well I I could help you out that's
not a problem so anyway I just wanted to
be as good as Boston as good as possible
all right well first of all I you know I
appreciate you reaching out to me so to
speak at my youtube channel saying let's
have a discussion just as that the other
Andriy from kiev did you know and I had
my conversation with him in oh I didn't
even notice I just thought I was
watching some of you
videos and I thought it was very
interesting how many languages you know
know some people they say on too old for
learning languages and well seems like
that's not really a thing I mean yes I
often say that I genuinely believe that
I'm 70 now I'm better at learning
languages today than when I was 16
uh-huh just a second
oh just for me to sync up the video and
the audio in it okay I'm ready all right
yeah so I think it's a JSON to do with
it I mean even if even if to some extent
our brain cells are starting to slow
down or whatever it's like this whole
issue of you know your need talent like
it doesn't matter if you're motivated if
you put in the time some might learn
faster some might learn better some
might learn more slowly but you can
learn so so the whole issue of you
better at 15 then at 60 or as you get
older you can't do this and that it has
no no impact on me at all just yeah I
hear a lot that people say in particular
about Japanese right that's really hard
and honestly ever since I started well
I've only been learning it for four
months now right but for the whole way
I part from writing because writing is
quite complex right I found it I didn't
think that it was difficult like at all
I I just I was just very interested in
Japanese culture right and I didn't
really think that it was a very
difficult language especially after
Russian well Russian is one of the two
of my well native languages because um
my parents come from the southern part
of Russia oh really
called kitchen ah oh yeah sure and the
news all the time huh I say very much in
the news all the time oh yeah
yeah and so my native language is
Chechen oh yeah and when I was in
kindergarten nobody could understand me
and neither could I understand anyone
else so they taught me my parents taught
me Russian of course right and and then
when I was in what well yet first rate I
was like almost seven years old I
started learning English and then I just
since maybe 2010 I got as ice I saw you
talk about in some of your videos that
you do you get a lot of input right
that's exactly what I did what I have
done with English I watched a lot of
phenomenal as I'm sure my viewers here
at YouTube are saying themselves Wow is
this guy ever good yeah you sound as if
you've been living in an
english-speaking country for many many
many years
really that's remarkable anybody say
Russian is difficult Chechen must be
difficult I have no idea about you know
languages in the Caucasus huh well
honestly since I I was taught Russian
and because of course I use Russian
every day because live in Moscow I
forgot Chechen quite a lot so I only
know a little bit I I speak it with my
mom sometimes right and I don't really
remember that that well but we have this
is the weirdest thing to me personally
we have four genders oh really
what's that we have what how do you get
four genders so I I know I think so this
is like feminine
well there's masks there's master
neutering Russia right yeah exactly
so there's he she and it right oh well
but they don't use them for objects oh
yeah yes they don't have genders in that
way but yeah in Russian as you know we
have three genders right
but in Chechen we have like feminine
masculine then like mutual feminine
mutual masculine in painting at first I
thought all right so FEMEN masculine is
for people right neutral feminine
neutral masculine is for objects wait no
objects can also be masculine it can be
even objects could be either one of the
four but general what it doesn't
surprise me because everything that
languages do as they develop naturally
over the course of histories all based
on conventions like if people agree that
they're gonna have four genders three
genders five two hundred two dinners
there's no real logical reason I always
say that in languages there's lots of
junk code there's lots of more stuff
there like we can understand like when I
started learning Russian and I I didn't
spend a lot of time on the grammar so
very often I didn't know what case
something was let's figure it out from
the context you know there's plenty of
stuff there of course it becomes clearer
when you understand the grammar better
but this is just a natural convention on
how people communicate make each other
feel good you know but let me ask you
now getting to Japanese so are you
learning the characters the kanji
yes I don't know that many I know and
maybe fifteen fifty okay no I had the
advantage when I was learning Japanese
that I had learned Chinese first so
there I had two characters which i think
is a big advantage because but don't you
still need to learn the couldn't reading
you learn the the yeah you know you need
to learn the on and kunio me in other
words they call it Japanese and Chinese
called Japanese version
of Chinese pronunciation but it doesn't
matter because I can start to read and
even if I can't pronounce the character
I know what the character means and so I
have a big head start in terms of
reading because the kana is not that
difficult to learn hiragana katakana but
the characters if you haven't done
characters there's a lot of character to
learn so it enabled me and I I believe
reading is extremely like I always say
reading is for vocabulary listening is
for speaking if you do a lot of
listening you get better at speaking but
you need worse nicely as a I'm sorry I
just wrote as I was watching like a lot
of contents online every time I was I
heard a new word I was like oh stop I
paused the video I went to Google
Translate it wasn't that bad for English
and I checked what the word was and then
I looked up several meanings in same
word and I thought in my head in what
context I can use that word because just
knowing the translation I think that's
only half of the problems right I think
it's more important to know in what
context you can use a certain work and
that's why I don't put a lot of effort
to looking things up in a dictionary
because AI forget it right away and be
it's only a small for many words
I mean tree is tree okay but but many
words you only get a small hint as to
what the word means and it's only when
you see it in many different contexts
that you start to get a real picture of
how that because of this yeah I'm sorry
to say one thing because of this I have
a lot of cases where I know an English
phrase or a word but I have no idea what
it is in question right so it's kind of
weird but that's good because the same
you know you you the sooner you get to
that stage where you're you're listening
or reading and it's becoming meaning
without you having to go through your
own language I mean that's better we
eventually I feel that we end up with a
like I feel in my mind I have a an
English language control center of my
brain I'm a French language controls
have Japanese language and of course my
with my weaker languages that control
center isn't so good like so when I
speak Russian I have a control center
I have two times speak more or less
naturally sometimes translating but I
speak with mistakes because the control
center isn't sufficiently well-developed
when I speak French I don't make many
mistakes and when I make and when I
speak English hopefully I make no
mistakes so you know you have all these
different control centers but yeah
Japanese you're saying I agree with you
if you if you remove the problem of the
kanji then I think that Japanese is
actually not a difficult language the
only difficulty is there are certain
structures in Japanese that are you know
different so you have to get used to
them I miss like in Russian who was used
okay when she first time I said you have
is reversed what's that all about
but actually after a while you get used
to that's how it said I'd never
translate Louvre I ceased as to you is
it just automatically means that you
know you have and in Japanese they have
this you know the you know
atashi Wow Burpo and at the verb at the
end is one thing and also these dividers
so atashi wa anata ye sorry oh Sam Hamas
and then more I'm Musashi agamous these
words that implied direction and level
of politeness when we're doing something
to someone else or receiving something
from someone else or going to someone
else basically that's it other than that
the tenses are pretty easy there's no
case and things like Russian they don't
have all the sort of verbs of motion and
aspects of verbs as Russian have they
don't have the complicated tenses that
the English or the you know the Romance
languages have Oh in Japanese huh you
know what I found difficult in Japanese
you know and maybe it's true to some
extent in all languages but I
particularly remember this being an
obstacle when I started learning
Japanese and that is that so many words
seem to sound the same because in fact
yes walk re Moscow re mas you know and
because in fact japanese has fewer
sounds than most because they have the
syllable for whatever reason they they
have fewer phonemes if you take all of
the different sounds all like their
vowels and you take the different
consonants and you'd look at phonemes
even if they were to write their
language with an alphabet rather than a
syllabary in fact they have fewer sounds
so with fewer sounds more words are
gonna sound the same so that to me was a
bit of a problem well I guess I still
have not encountered that problem
because well in my Anki I have about
2000 notes and I'll assume some of them
are phrases so I guess maybe I learned
one and a half thousand okay actual
words mm-hmm i but yeah i'm just
starting out so i guess i will only run
into that problem later on but i've seen
in my dictionary when i look up a word
for some particular words that will be
like twenty meanings right some are
birds some are nouns some are adjectives
and well yeah I just I guess I'll notice
this I mean it's just it's a bit like me
with Korea now with the Japanese I was
in the situation that I was living in
Japan so I was doing a lot of reading
and listening and then I started
speaking to people and I just just kind
of learned it but I'm learning Korean
adlink so every time I look something up
in Korean like it's the same you look up
especially the short words in Korean
it's got seven different meanings all
right and and none of them are related
so and none of them seem to fit to fit
the context so I just proceed like I
feel in language learning you have to
accept a lot of uncertainty a lot of
fuzziness you don't really understand
you just keep going and eventually
things fall into place but we can you
know we've spoken a bit in English now
we can speak in Russian if you want just
to very out a bit large part whisky nah
no yeah
if the chimú we we her teacher is the
judge appoints qz ah no it's not general
yeah my shots Madrid's [ __ ] block ABC
was married upon ski Eggman a patent no
a pet oh yes into salsa
Rapunzel quilt or a heap adam emmenecker
commercial side are ok he yeah hotel
special no yes innocence it solely upon
her he but tom cactus mammals to verily
among ago varied some of her college to
be a is Chow coin which is in Australia
I know I shall not be left at college to
be a this job no music no nanny Courtney
does not command list oh yeah
he just it is Anna my items that you
might say spoke of any chicken is still
amazes person enveloped okay no just
never eat Peru ski epitome
PI upon ski livestock to 30 minutes of
at the Neogene log at the ocean watching
krotkiy strokes Govinda no yeah yeah she
the opponent Tom yeah Mook cha cha
Fiorina Charlie the Turkish lira cheetah
yeah yeah be was more not rozhkov arias
let me know posny Yun is now says mrs.
O'Fallon yeah Tommy she'll give it that
down no Naga yeah no II presume we are
prayerful of the opponent yeah which mmm
Malkovich pocket I ski he has now
Yanni's night 3tc she can still eat ECG
relief even thousands on cancer can G no
cancer yeah
couple Nikon's compiled kanji kanji de
now my gorram Kenzi Kenzi okay candy but
ice can panic attack packet packet I
still can't get the nose by Elsa he ties
me
he bugs game oh fish such a stir porky
pies game pocket ask you know yeah yeah
I'm a we do maybe do her yellow leaf
Catalina's right suture upon ski can can
see [ __ ]
Atanas Whitechapel ski kit I ski cat ice
cave au Zika yo beef as focus how it is
he it once here I mean resorts no yeah I
just got a stove pocket I ski yeah
he tied ck da auga Veritas ye pi syuh de
it Anna's writes a Hansel kanji bhai
upon ski at the tadka prize machine
yah-yah-yah Polsky prize misciagna
tourism a yellow leaf hands
Kaji justin is now an Oscar Zoroaster
monster geography hero bifida no I mean
yeah and America left you but almost a
yahoo jet is now that still it is its
year a glyphis
late is wrong you know click on it later
up is we touch upon ski no it does
cactus nice G hiragana katakana it a pro
stock it's a khaki Kitty's is Florida
Itachi kanji
digest onions now Caqueta prize message
yes now take a
Smith's story it was not yet
sure someone killed aya yes
monday rinsky yes come donkey Roz new
scheme
ah no pre attempt is more let's knock
where we lose the mobile missiles no
limini upon scania bill watching through
near below gentlemen no no go je yes the
onion years Nile heat iced tea fish Anya
guy yellow blue
no it must a good name no no Jean no can
you say your thumb she'll buy tomorrow
to go slow yeah dummy I'll be watching
police need only a super Yakuts the
point no get a vodka martini with gotta
say no no Kenya's nah nah deposit is
Tokyo but the most a pestilence Allah
but um yeah cat yes the Shinkansen the
Nara Kyoto
Shinkansen it be supposed to paste lucky
skirt's 9:00 last night
no can use na Nara Kyoto torch in
watching interest no chin Zorba up Adam
John Isner
Takayama a tough girl it is Nagoya phase
dome treat your son Adam another poet
competes mystic II believe you have to
get up in a Naga capiche gracias
- peace be upon you ah potometer
watching hm
Newton your servant know it asteroid
therapies but the most of the opponent
religion in a robe pursue the it out you
don't know no problem coverage para upon
ski highlight over now job with this guy
hi Thank You ver kappa da da da da
hey come Tyson now I got a switch my
brain let's start again you know it su
cara y su cara young go thank you she
hides me mastica boku wa it she got
sunni she had him a master Wow
Baker Walker Lindh he or she has even
much stuff hot so money he Joanie Edith
another God's presence in you
ah so hot so hot such as we can
reproduce Kiki Jim Persky okay so no one
else knew I'm not a god Yoga gets come
my knee
you don't go no bank you're had a master
pink Yoshi hi Jimmy Master PO na Jung
cogito four months shut the eagerly
yeah young target for months hi yo maybe
it's an eye I'm not that guy
nihongo Bank your she Hajime master
Micah gets my knee I thank you she has
me master hey Nick
sorry doctor in that day
rhythms lucida sorry doctoral anatawa
øg øg know what you see anata wa boku
sugoku you know my brain is running in
the wrong doesn't sue Google future no
Johnny
so what cool sugoku Yoko and Ashish must
do you know yet another guy - you know
what you need to know you know what what
I mean is - you know what - you know
it's very interesting it's very hard to
switch out of Russia co2 bazooka now
there is your use of words Cocteau
bazooka kotoba su chi o ducats kiemas
certain kotoba is word right su ke
masses to use sky right so kotta vasu
chi use of words quads okay what he
Johnny D Johnny
she's Antechinus natural she's in his
nature
anata no koto bazooka wha he journey
Edith his journey he does another shot
from to this yo
so step more cut what a chica I musta
yoni as I said
watashi wa e musta yoni this by the way
is a very useful expression in Japanese
no yoni he must I mean the way I said
what actua he must I only as I said
watashi wa e must i oniy as i say yeah
it's funny my brain just won't go into
japanese imagine what it is like to
switch between 12 languages actually as
I speak Japanese very well but for some
reason I am now it's very interesting
we'll have to put this video up my brain
is stuck in Russian okay
you a new home go there ma sorry sorry
oh the cocoon money MA so didn't you add
todo I thought you know keyboard okay
night to guys what action or keyboard or
kyanite Oh akima same that's one of
those Japanese expressions I have I
didn't I haven't bought one okay
no watashi wa watashi wa EEMA EEMA
Nihon otaku nihongo de Kakutani nee nee
but actually no keyboard or night you
don't have a japanese like a japanese
language on your keyboard re Monsieur
Aramis you're not gonna choreo condom
hiragana nakaya's never thought you know
mark there hiragana nee Kai dead
so stay koko de share screen and people
was very much tied ponies company now
get a Madoka
for junior can I use your food to Neela
normally food soon Eva cackling this yo
knock that off
EEMA and and share some Tony Hong go
home Tony Jaa's of us
yeah yeah I don't have food to on it
flew to LA for two ah
hey one of these there's so many use for
little expressions like normally Fasulo
- ah - ah
you have to look this up is just write
them down you know I'd write them if I
could figure out where on the stupids oh
here's a little symbol okay here we are
I don't this guy sous-sous down Fortuna
is tsutsu you see that so - food soon
are afoot soon ah etc okay bingo
kazoo did that get through to now elf it
sua Fasulo normally hmm
- uh no thanks your cousin and this your
new home wa watashi wa nihongo Kaka -
can I can I
khaki my sister right a cop is right -
right
so money but I am very impressed
Taeyang etus I'm not done on the on go
yong-pan gets cut
- is difficult no 910 is very at I Han
can also be the tie him this is like
it's terrible but Taihang Edith very
good
he Journal Edith Joan Akitas tae-hee
this I think I talked as I must yeah he
journey he journey right
it's very right he journey hmm he Johnny
Day oh whoops I'll give you that he
journey the food - ah he journey
kono kata Baba - Go Go Go car Akutan
this young Chui Goku is challenger Cara
from camasta da ah hi he juni the fetch
our pocket ice key feature food to Putin
they chant hijab hmm what sir is to
write 2 2 4 2 4 2 is normal common ah
fits this or this now you can look that
up then you can't mean I think mother I
donate yeah kanji on it kanji Oh benkyo
suru no one can Gio kanji
- no I - coconut candies wrong
congeal bank your suit
thank you sir hey okay suru koto wa
that's how the structure is in jail I
can do benkyo suru koto wa he Johnny
ty said to this he join me paints up to
this paisa is important ah
and he Johnny is very very hey Johnny
and he Joanie taisetsu na boo boo no
like the biggest part I boo boo boo fan
in Chinese die bone in Japanese diaper
will no kotoba what - go go go Cara
camasta so the words came from Chinese
don't you pass in the show go dip a
scent oh hi welcome adelardo could you
purchase and 50 cent 50 percent by
neuter tokuji % oh no kotoba
my stuff hi doctor ah da cunha you
understand by 4
kanji benkyo suru koto wa he Joanie
ty says this pie said sir is very
important very important hi dr. aha the
learning learning kanji is very
important hmm absolutely absolutely
because the vocabulary it's the core
it's the base of the vocabulary we'll
just finish off in anus and I
unfortunately have to run but just what
was the word that you said what I need
like I don't need you one huh do you
know what
so you know you know what so you know so
you know what hey it means to say so you
know ah
so you know what I'm gonna finish off
here quickly cuz I gotta run but in all
languages there are these handy phrases
then make everything fall together and
seem natural
yeah I don't know what what I mean to
say to you Noah or to you koto wa told
you Cordova or no you oniy know
okay or maybe I bought that do I go for
example yeah anyway so Jemaine you done
in this kid or you know the words on
then done then is it's a shame yeah
unfortunately unfortunately it's a shame
Oh
all those unfortunate it's a shame done
then this carry Domo and there's nothing
they do in Japanese done then that's not
done and SKT Domo and they throw the but
in at the end which doesn't mean
anything right done then this kid all
EEMA but actually God he cannot get it
on our own I I have to go and I as you
know in Japanese they have this funny it
cannot get it about if I don't go he can
it cannot get about you can i if I don't
go it won't be good so oh I just
remembered my friend taught me that
expression yeah it's something like
knocking about yeah I remember that kid
about another night not get away can I
not get about another night that means
if it if I don't do it it won't be it's
not acceptable kind of thing and that's
how you say I have to it's like I must I
must say my house yeah yeah it's a bit
like for genders in Chechen you know
what I mean this is how the language is
no more explanations no reason that's
how it is okay listen Dennis very
interesting I'm gonna have to run any
Denny good luck to you and time not at
all enjoying I'm always happy to talk to
a language enthusiast okay that makes
the world smaller when people can
communicate in a variety of languages
and and given your age you should end up
with about 20 or 30 languages okay
five be much I'll see you later bye bye
you